en marchant dans les rues de côte des
neiges notre dame de grâce gracia qu'à
ceux qui katawal infirmière de 35 ans
apprivoise peu à peu son nouveau statut
de mère s
comme ça
il aura fallu un recomptage pour que je
sois confirmé sa victoire contre lionel
perez un pilier de la politique
municipale
les gens choisis la vision de projet
montréal donc d'une métropole à échelle
humaine je pense que les oui les gens
choisis aussi mon profil comme j'ai dit
une infirmière quelqu'un qui on peut
faire confiance je suis une citoyenne
qui est engagée depuis longtemps je
pense que ça c'est un élément qui fait
la différence est ce que mon origine a
fait la différence parce qu'il ya
plusieurs personnes ici qu'ils aiment a
eu le temps en fait le con et une
mairesse d'arrondissement qui est aussi
issu de la diversité
grâce yakata wa arrivent au québec en
1989 à l'âge de 3 ans ses parents
s'installent à québec où elle passe sa
jeunesse et fait toutes ses études mais
en 2009 elle choisi d'amorcer sa
carrière d'infirmière à l'hôpital
général juif de montréal j'ai eu la
réflexion mais je me suis dit moi j'ai
envie de vives j'ai envie d'expérimenter
finalement une société qui plus diverses
puisque pour ça que j'ai choisi
spécifiquement que des neiges puis notre
côte des neiges notre dame de grâce puis
le potager pour ça parce que je vois là
j'étais un peu tanné d'être toujours là
la seule
noir quelque part j'ai fait toutes mes
études comme ça bénévoles engagés et
membre de plusieurs ca et maintenant
gestionnaires en santé elles côtoient
les résidents de côte-des-neiges depuis
douze ans une population qui parle plus
de 80 langues clairement notre montréal
doit rester métropole francophone on est
la population immigrante comment on
verra en eux vu d'autres est vraiment
comme j'ai dit un peu lors de ma
première conférence de presse est un
parcours du combattant donc tout ce
qu'on peut faire pour s'assurer de
s'intégrer on va le faire vous êtes les
premiers que je rencontrerai
couronne bon c'est un couronnement
d'avoir une mairesse
je suis la communauté noire bravo on est
honoré de
cette élection on a besoin de changement
et je pense que je le perçois ge
positivement et on va c'est travailler
avec la nouvelle mairesse et pour
pouvoir donner du mieux du quartier sa
priorité pour l'arrondissement acheter
des terrains ou des immeubles pour
augmenter le nombre de logements
abordables
je le sais qu'il ya beaucoup d'attentes
puis il ya beaucoup de besoins jeu
contente qu'on fait ça commence à
travailler je commence à juge première
rencontre avec le caucus de projet
montréal des coûts angie aujourd'hui une
rencontre qui ce jour-là a lieu à
l'hôtel de ville de montréal qu'elle
visait seulement pour la deuxième fois
c'est toujours aussi impressionnant
toujours aussi impressionnant sûrement
privilège est ici
dirigée elle le sait signifie parfois
prendre des décisions difficiles mais
elle promet de demeurer l'infirmière
derrière la mairesse même si je suis
capable de dire à certaines personnes
parfois mais malheureusement on n'ira
pas dans la direction que que tu m'a
proposé ben je le fais avec
bienveillance quand même sur la scène
municipale gracia katawal se fait déjà
remarquer deux femmes de tête et de
coeur qu'une femme organisée mais en
même temps qu'à l'est le coeur à la
population ou à l' écoute on a beaucoup
discuté comment je peux mettre en
pratique tout ce que j'ai entendu c'est
de l'excitation c'est un peu moi j'ai
fait du théâtre dans ma ville donc c'est
un peu comme juste avant de rentrer sur
5 mhz et utilise toute cette énergie là
pour assurer de bien performics de
l'énergie positive donc c'est un peu
comme ça que je me sens
prête à jouer le rôle principal dans
l'arrondissement le plus peuplé de
montréal ici jean sébastien cloutier
radio-canada m'ont rien